120 milliards d'euros c'est ce que
coûterait à la france les 8 semaines de
confinement c'est le constat de
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques
on déplore une chute de 18 % de la
consommation des ménages et un chômage
partiel pour 12 millions de salariés du
secteur privé les dépenses du budget
général s'élève elle à 84 milliards
d'euros contre 75 milliards un an
auparavant
quant aux recettes elles sont en repli
au 31 mars
61 milliards contre 65 à la même période
en 2010 9 après l'amortissement du choc
on rentre dans la zone de risque et la
zone de vrais risques
elle n'est pas dans un an ou deux un
damné entre maintenant et la famille
2020 ou là si on ne peut pas attention
on aura multiplication de fellini donc
il faut qu'on regarde tous les secteurs
les plus fragiles les entreprises les
plus fragiles il faut qu'on ait des
dispositifs spécifiques
le produit intérieur brut français
devrait reculer de 8,2 pour cent cette
année en raison de la pandémie
quant à la dette du pays shell devrait
se creuser à 116 5% de son pib contre
98,1 en 2019
des prédictions alarmistes présenté ce
mercredi par la commission européenne ue
member states tous les états membres de
l'union européenne devraient connaître
une grave récession cette année
c'est en grèce en italie en espagne en
croatie et dans une moindre mesure en
france que l'activité économique devrait
se contracter le plus grand dommage in
france en france l'économie devrait se
contracter d'environ 8% cette année
l'économie devrait commencer à se
redresser progressivement au cours du
second semestre 2020 comme la plupart
des états membres
la france devrait être soutenue par des
mesures budgétaires visant à assurer la
liquidité des entreprises et à protéger
l'emploi
l'union européenne qui s'attend donc à
affronter la pire crise économique de
son histoire alors qu'à l'automne
dernier bruxelles
et une croissance d'environ 1 % en 2020
dans la zone euro c'est une récession
historique qui devrait s'abattre sur le
vieux continent elle pourrait être de 7
7%
et c'est en juin que le plan de
financement de la relance de l'économie
européenne devrait être soumis au vote
des chefs d'état et de gouvernement des
27 pays membres
un programme qui consiste en un mélange
de transfert et de prêts de long terme
l'union européenne et les états membres
ont déjà convenu de mesures
extraordinaires pour atténuer l'impact
notre rétablissement collectif dépendra
de la poursuite de réponse forte et
coordonnée au niveau européen et
national
nous sommes plus forts ensemble encore
faut-il que les pays de l'union
européenne veulent toujours en faire
partie l'italie par exemple a dû se
tourner vers la chine la russie le
venezuela ou encore cuba pour lutter
contre le coc vide 19 en début de crise
bruxelles s'étant montrés pour le moins
discrète d'ailleurs l'hostilité envers
l'ue eux atteint des sommets dans le
pays
un italien sur deux se dit prêt
aujourd'hui à ce que son pays quitte
l'union européenne